[Musique]
bonsoir les petits ont soir ou lolo soko
je suis chargé je me demande nounours ce
que tu vas faire avec tout ce papier
vous allez voir patron vous allez voir
europe bon le seul propos pom pom
pom pom
[Musique]
c'est une idée annonce j'arrive au soir
mais au fond ce que tu cherchais qu'est
ce que tu nous as papier beaucoup de
papier nous allons faire blin d'avion en
papier
et nous les enverrons tous sur le nuage
de mon petit pas trop bien des mines
[Rires]
ont fermé les yeux et compté jusqu'à 3
[Musique]
3 et voilà
qui
va s'envoler évidemment regardé je
souffle dessus
[Musique]
le haut à vos patrons
ils veulent bien
en solo
lundi dont je croyais en avion au oui
hélas changer d'air voyons voir mais
c'est une fête on dire
pour l'instant ne soyez pas si précieux
la première les dons reçus à vous donne
ma parole
monsieur
[Musique]
les enfants
quelle drôle de l'autre il n'y rien de
crue mais
voilà des pick up des sapins ça veut
dire que quand il jouait talamo talent
des chefs d'états d'âme l'état veut
tabac à
ses plumes au cse député gillet qui les
accompagnent elle le papa des cornichons
tous les soirs je de l'aquitaine vous
rendormir son petit garçon
allons au lit comme votre petite amie
corps du show la cognition allez
salut on va écrire tu sais bonne nuit
les petits
là j'étais là leur
dos au mur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci nounours il est très beau en avion
je les ai reçus sur le nez oui aux
patrons je voulais vous en expédier
encore beaucoup d'autres mais nous avons
reçu une lettre de cornichons j oubliais
dans me and north allant en route bonne
nuit des enfants faute de boer heures
[Musique]